[Music]
you are watching The Press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
Economist Zoe Williams and Mary McLeod
former conservative MP and advisor to
the Royal household who's now chief
executive of the charity business in the
community welcome to you both it's very
nice to have you in person who makes the
change so let's see what's on some of
the front pages for you now dominated of
course by the coronation day well day of
Destiny the express pictures the ancient
chair made in the year 1300 upon which
the king will be crowned tomorrow
The Daily Mail has an image of Charles
on the day who was invested as Prince of
Wales in 1969.
similar words again in the times which
shows the king meeting and greeting
people lining the coronation route
earlier today
shows the crown itself with the words he
will not only wear the crown he will
bear the weight of history and the hopes
of a Nation
while the sun shows two crowns one each
for the king and queen and the headline
his and hers
the telegraph quotes from The King's
coronation vow to be given tomorrow I
come not to be served but to serve
the star reveals that an Irish Wolfhound
called Sheamus will play a leading role
in the coronation parade along the Mal
looks very handsome too away from the
ceremony itself the eye looks at the
battle the King has ahead of him to
secure the future of the monarchy in the
face of changing public opinion
and the day's other big story the
financial times weekend edition leads
where the recriminations within the
conservative party after its disastrous
showing at the local elections which has
given labor New Hope of returning to
power
the guardian 2 leads with that story
describing it as a crushing result for
the Tories
foreign
reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight to buy Zoe
Williams and Mary McLeod welcome again
to both of you let's um start off by
having a look at the the mail front page
um and their headline his day of Destiny
the day that he's waited uh so long a
record weight in fact before he could
arrive at this point Mary
well yes it's I mean this is an amazing
occasion and just as we're here and it
is lovely to to be here we get a sense
of the excitement that's building up for
this
um but it's also on a historical
occasion and this is is trying to show
and portray that that this is something
that
um that none of us have seen in our
lifetime in Coronation and therefore
this is a really important moment it's
also a global occasion and just as we
saw today with the heads of state and
the heads of the Realms of the
Commonwealth and coming to London and
having those events today
the the king
um is about two billion people are in
the Commonwealth so it's a lot of people
that are involved in this
um as well as the 14 Realms and the
tears King off so it's a really
important moment for that
um globally and then but also also is
nice about all of this is that it
actually also then brings in the local
because it's also about community and
we'll see see tomorrow yes the military
and the Pomp and Circumstance with what
we are you know so incredibly good at in
Britain but we will also have that
Community element as part of it and and
I and others will be there in the Abbey
representing some of those Charities
that the King has been heavily involved
with for for many years and has done an
amazing amount of work trying to change
lives and transforming communities and
and helping communities Thrive so it
really is a moment that is really
special for for the country but also for
individuals right across the nation and
Zoe how do you think that the King has
um done in terms of inclusion you know
as mayor was saying there are very many
people in the community involved
do you think about something he's really
worked hard to achieve it's really
difficult for it's really difficult for
the king I think because he's you know
he has track record of
making the right noises that would
please the kind of people who are
interested in inclusion but it's a very
very difficult he's he's kind of
ascended to the crown in a very
difficult time for the nation so there
there will certainly be people saying
they they cannot stand the display and
the excess in the middle of the cost of
living crisis and that is you know it's
a difficult situation and I don't think
there would have been a perfect course
to navigate through it I think the male
front page was really interesting
because you know absolute new standard
is that you use the most recent picture
of the person it's just like a given
it's it you you kind of have to
um and as a result of that you see on
all the other pages on all the other
papers that didn't want to use a kind of
picture of the king as he is now they
use either the crown or the or the
throne they use some kind of image to
stand in for him and that is well I
think because in order to give it his
proper sense of kind of circumstance you
don't really want to see him as a nice
smiling
73 year old guy shaking people's hands
you want a kind of sense of occasion you
want a sense of majesty you want a kind
of massive thing so they're using visual
metaphors instead of using the king as
he is but the male just went full
throttle and used him at 20 years old
which is actually quite bold as a news
decision because it makes it gives it a
sense of kind of drama I mean you look
at that front page and you think wow he
was this he's been waiting for me yes
and and it puts a whole new spin on the
entire trajectory
um so I think I mean I you know even
while I think that they probably did
produce news values a little I think
they did the right thing
do you remember I think the footer also
shows is that he in essence has been an
apprentice to the queen for a long time
which therefore you know he's been in
training mode and seeing the best of the
best on how to be a monarch and now he's
King and this is his moment to to for
this coronation so I think it's showing
that stability that he has learned from
that
um the the real understanding of the
role that he has built over so many
years and and I think the the sense of
community comes also and not just it'll
be you know others like me in the Abbey
who are from who are representing the
community but also that the Walkabout
today was an example of that where he
just went out and Shook Ones with people
really informally and we saw that Human
Side to him and and it's the work that
he does every day going out round the
country talking to people in in their
local communities yeah since I as you
say the other papers also not choosing
to to show that the king as he is now
they
pictured the crown there he will not
only wear the crown he will bear the
weight of history and the hopes of a
Nation hi to do you know what I really
felt for the mirror with this page
because they're not natural that they're
not natural establishment
journalists but they are natural
royalists so A Moment Like This poses a
real problem for them because they
haven't got all the kind of language of
the establishment and yet they don't
want to alienate anyone so they come out
with this basically word salad what does
bear the weight of history mean what
does the hopes of I mean in what sense
does he bear the hopes of a Nation I
mean it's it's sort of like
it's sort of like somebody trying to be
a monarchist really really hard and you
know hats off they they are trying but I
don't think they've quite got it
but I also think the hopes of a Nation
at a time where so much around us is
negative and there's young people who
are really struggling and self-harming
and there's lots of atrocities happening
around the world that they where do you
give hope to the people of a country and
especially young people and I think that
where I see the hope is in being able to
establish something about what's
positive about Britain what's supporting
the areas in Britain that really needs
need need help and recognition and I
think that to me is embodied in some of
that whereas there's the the hopes of a
nation and then we look at the eye and
they're talking about the the battle
that he has ahead to secure the the
future of the the monarchy Zoe and you
know nobody knows what the future will
be but it does suggest that he has a
struggle on his hand if he wants to
maintain the monarchy in its current
form but look I think the main so there
there's a kind of challenge there is
there's a three-way Challenge and one
part of it's much more serious than the
other two parts one part of it the the
more serious part is the Commonwealth
you know the kind of distributed nations
of the Commonwealth a lot of them are
just not keen on on having a monarch
anymore and uh but that doesn't that
doesn't preclude them from being in the
Commonwealth no she can be a republic
and still be in the comments but it does
make it very diff it makes it puts the
royal family in a more difficult
situation than it puts the members of
the Commonwealth if you see what I mean
because part of their legitimacy and
part of their Grandeur was that they
weren't just the royal family of the
United Kingdom but they were kind of
standing for this enormous body of
people and so and you know obviously
King Charles is going to take it with
good part good grace if if he if a
number of nations declare independence
or you know declare then our republics
but it it is it is a very serious
challenge to the royal family to be
sustained in the way that it is at the
moment
um by you know in the United Kingdom the
second of course it's the Rifts within
the family because that kind of Harry
and Megan's situation isn't going away
and the third challenge is the the kind
of obvious slight friction between the
him and Princess Anne last week when
he's talking about kind of slimming the
family down and she's saying well I you
know it's already slimmed down
um you know they they they're obviously
live debates within the Inner Circle
about how large this family should be
following the death of the queen
um I think I think they'll be able to
figure that out I think that the Harry
and Megan situation is going to be a
little bit less pretty and I think the
Commonwealth situation is going to be
more important
let's talk about the service tomorrow
and we know that the theme is one of the
king coming to to serve and not be
served and that's very much a theme
that's he's wanted to to get through
yes and I think that is a very real
thing for him
um it's uh he has spent his life to this
point
um in this role as when he was Prince of
Wales and now King in essence serving
um across the whether it was um the
across the United Kingdom and now of
course also Commonwealth but it's he he
sees his rule very much as as the queen
did actually this has it sounds very
much like I thought the queen would have
said I'm here to serve she very much saw
her role as there was the elite Queen
and so so this is something I think is a
really
um engaging title because I think that
is really truly him and that's seen in
the work he has done and I don't think
he often gets the credit for the
millions of lives that he has
transformed over those years whether
it's with organizations like mine
business in the community or whether
it's with the princess trust and other
organizations where he has literally
worked really hard on issues that
decades ago were not popular or were
seen as a new and and yet but he talked
about it he started a race campaign in
1995 with business in the community
before it was really talked about and
the same when it came to the environment
so he has always been out there in
communities and understanding them and
being in touch with them okay let's have
a look at the guardian now and they're
concentrating on the local election
results crushing result for the Tories
uh says the guardian so yeah sorry I'm
trying not to look smug but I'm failing
miserably try harder
I mean I'm actually surprised they LED
as much on Charles as they did because
they've kind of covered half the front
page but that's really not a guardian
constituency the guardian readership is
only interested in this devastating blow
of the conservative party and it is it
is not great right I mean it's like that
they were
governments sitting governments always
always overplay how bad they think their
losses are going to be in order that
they don't have to eat Humble Pie when
the results come in and the Tories were
saying they were gonna they were looking
at 800 seats lost so that was their
worst case that was the that was their
above worst case scenario and they've
sailed 200 seats above their worst case
scenario so the things are not great in
the Tory party and those those people
who were predicting an election this
year against every other voice are
suddenly looking a lot stronger because
there's going to be there is no
functional way the conservative party
can have another leadership revolt and
play Someone Else
unelected by any kind of mandate into 10
Downing Street so they've they're either
with Rishi or they're calling us an
Appalachian
um there are there's massive
disgruntlement within the party
especially from allies of Boris Johnson
I know is astonishing that he would have
allies at this stage but the the he sort
of stands for something from for a kind
of certain constituency within the party
so there's a huge disgruntlement and
Readiness to launch some kind of
Kamikaze attack
um which I don't think we should rule
out by any means on the uh and also what
those Rebels will be thinking is that it
doesn't look as good for labor as it
should
um you know the the the lib Dems gained
almost as many seats as the labor party
did the greens did better than I've ever
seen the green has done in my life now
is it sorry I will shut up
but you know the the whole thing and
I've seen this so many times across 30
years is that people vote green and
locals and then labor in generals
because they kind of see Greener so they
see locals as a chance to make their
values felt and they see general
elections as the point in which you have
to get serious and get the party you
want in so I wouldn't at all extrapolate
that the greens are going to get loads
of seats in the general election but I
do extrapolate that the labor party is
not winning the hearts and Minds that it
needs to Mary do you agree with that
that it's maybe a protest vote in terms
of the greens but yes more serious in
terms of the you know several things so
first they're just not a good night for
the Prime Minister
um and and I think to some extent some
of those results were anticipated with
the pools that we've had over recent
months so that so it's definitely uh I
think the Prime Minister armed the party
chairman has come out already seeing how
disappointed they are with the results I
do think there is often a protest for
the local elections and I think there's
also something that labor needs to do to
win hearts and Minds I also just regard
that I think it's a week's a long time
in politics and there is probably
another year to the next election so
therefore it's up to the Prime Minister
I do not think there'll be a change of
leader so therefore it is up to the
prime minister to deliver on his five
priorities I think the public it's
democracy the public will then vote to
see whether if they feel he has achieved
anything that they believe is is
worthwhile in that in that year so he's
fairly still new and Rural so I so I'm
not surprised by those results but it's
it's he really has to get with with the
cabinet deliver now for the country and
or there will be
um yeah a really difficult general
election coming up okay